okay test penis one through three test
penis one two three
can you hear me okay
we're gonna do this now that you're back
in business we can focus on the morning
star horuseus towers emails okay man I
miss Kat the guy was a bro GATT was up
bro what was that something [__]
cruise ship doing over there yeah ain't
none of my business you know what I'm
saying you don't suck there's no like
secret oratory that you collect like I
went to the highest [__] building in
here and I tried to think like okay
maybe there's probably like some secret
achievement or Easter egg thing at the
top and [__] [__] up there and now I
I jumped off they're gonna got me
achievement for biggest joke nothing
[__] sucks
okay
hey okay help
[__] [__] Dex
holy [__] I should not have flown over
that [__] oh okay [__] painting this
is original bug that back in the day
when me and the twins were all tense as
soon as how we just let them know we're
taking over their business I doubt that
deals gonna hold she remember the pony
show I mean off that Christmas list a
long time anyway about me the morning
star okay well party once the works done
I'll call you when I make another move
against the morning star [__] I went
this whole way for a [__] that I what
a crazy crap okay what the [__] is she
got on about how she looking at craps
okay well let me get out of the [__]
crap
I had it how do you get out of it is
anyone [__] now I can't shine I get
out of here
okay okay Jess that's not the way out
looking for five can exit this bear yet
yeah yeah yeah okay there we go there we
go back onto pips after the last one
don't think Suzy oh yeah yeah
[__] rock cider oxide a [__] Belding
okay no way man oh yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yes it does that our children
have sized gang culture and turns
sociopathic madmen into heroes no ok
those responsible for this act of terror
will be found and held accountable
ok the stag initiative marks a milestone
in taking back the streets of America
notice thanks and that was the stag
initiative so what's the lead very
discreet so one I pretend to be an
eccentric millionaire kind of I'm gonna
auction you off as a sex slave huh
[__] that oh quit being a [__] and get
in the veil wait what the [__] is going
on here
okay God God God yes Tata's okay I say I
jacked up that booty that booty
I like yeah
okay that's sucking through this
that's [__] dead Chasez okay I got
this [__] [__] is a sniper
honey snipers are there
[__] everyone looks so gorgeous right
now what the [__] oh that's me it's
maybe that bowtie okay I guess I can't
go there right can i no no
how's out [__] thought that's my girl
[__] that guy's good whatever happens it
is going to be perfect
shut that [__] time where they [__]
in here oh yeah there are a lot of
[__] in here
a lot of enslaved [__] man haha okay
time to start guessing okay all the
pictures of what's in here
snap that [__] snap that [__] snap
that [__] snap that [__] I got a
[__] [__] and I got guns okay okay
what's the password [__] already at me
I don't get it
can I get those dildos a lot of dildos
in this get holy [__] that is a huge
[__] okay how do i free this [__]
anyone oh hi for that [__]
okay I guess I feel later okay how do I
[__] free the big person anyone
[__] now I'm trying to free this [__]
yeah what's in here no dude I got afraid
like all I'm Tom Walker
gone a little back but I can't [__] it
I'm just gonna go and this [__] is so
hot holy [__] she's hot well I gotta say
she's [__] a hot
okay sorry Olga looks like you're gonna
be in here for a while
holy [__] that was Island look at this
beautiful beautiful ladies has to do
something okay wait dice is free like
the Olga [__] and I free this [__]
what's on here
like that time to go okay
you sound unsure okay
ah let's go let's go hey what's over
here
oh okay nothing
okay okay let's go
[__] it's a big [__]
and not use this
oh [__] my [__] [__]
it's a burning ditch out for Harambee